foreign
s us up next in Greenville South
Carolina Adam welcome to the show
hey George and Rachel how you guys doing
we're doing great how can we help
well um I've got a car problem I'm
hoping maybe you guys could help me make
a decision on I have a very old Toyota
Camry that is uh this is this was my
baby step two and three car nice and um
mechanically I mean I mean this car is
old enough to be registered as a classic
car that's how old it is what year is it
hit in 1997. oh nice yeah
um mechanically it is still Dependable
like it you know it runs fine but the
suspension is pretty much shot
and to get that fixed is probably going
to cost just about what the car is worth
and I'm trying to decide if it'd be
better because like right now you know
the used car Market's insane
um so I mean if I could
potentially upgrade to something for
just a few thousand more
you know of what I've got in my
emergency fund would that be a good idea
so are you in baby step four now do you
have a fully funded emergency fund and
you're out of debt yes yes I am okay
have you been saving for an upgrading
car
I started I mean I I just I should
preface I just hit beta stuff for like
in February oh March this is newer so
I'm this is this yeah this is recent
well I would continue saving I I think
at this point you upgrade the car man
you're not in debt there's no reason to
be driving around a 25 year old car at
this point I want you to get a different
kind of Dave Carr which is your upgrade
now that you're out of debt you've
worked hard to do that and build the
emergency fund so I would save up for a
used car paying cash it doesn't need to
be crazy but it needs to be better than
the 97 Camry with the shot suspension so
how much can you sell it for when it's
not like just as is
I could probably get about 2 000 for it
maybe okay and it's impressive and if
you fixed it
how much did how much do you say the
repairs were
uh about two thousand about two thousand
oh that's right what it's worth and then
how much could you sell it for if it was
fixed
I I really don't know if fixing it would
up the uh the value of it very much
because it's just like four thousand
okay yeah yeah it's just an old car sure
yeah yeah so Adam I would sell as is you
know get the 2 000 put some money
um that you need and it's drivable right
I'm trying to think of how urgent this
is for you like is it yeah yeah it's
drivable and it's still a you know it's
a safe car it's just and just I'm just
like I said I'm just been going back and
forth on well should I just drive it
till the wheels fall off or should I
think you're getting close to that atom
for sure so yeah I would yes I think
you've done a great job
um and I think yeah this is the point
where you're able to upgrade and I think
that that's awesome so selling it for 2K
whatever money you have saved over the
next couple of months and and the fact
that you don't you know your emergency
fund and everything is funded I wouldn't
touch that so I would just save on the
side uh put a couple more Grand together
and you could Step Up significantly oh
yeah to a seven eight thousand dollar
car is gonna feel a whole lot different
than what you're driving right now
you're probably looking at you know a
2010 uh simple sedan I think that would
do the trick and it would feel like a
giant upgrade from what you're driving
now but that's our the logic on it is
will you recoup what you put into it and
so if it's worth two grand and you put
two grand in well it's got to be worth
four grand or more to be worth it
otherwise just sell it as is and save up
cash and upgrade
awesome question I really
for sure and thanks for the call and I
think that that's the that's the
stepping up in car where you start to
you drive like no one else a letter you
can drive like no one else and so you
know he saves up you know a couple
Grands and he steps up to an 8 000 car
he drives that for maybe a year as he
saves on the side and that's the great
thing about cars they're not forever so
you could there's always another again
if you wanted and put the money you've
saved and keep just stepping up and so
that's the power and doing it with cash
as you do it slowly but it doesn't mean
you can never have a great car yes
people think well the Ramsay plan is you
drive crappy cars your whole life you
look in our parking lot there's there's
some real nice cars out there and
there's some beater cars out there I
think people are all over their money
Journey So Adam you've done the work to
get out of debt so I just want you to
upgrade because I want that for you you
deserve it at this point you've done the
hard work